bonsoir monsieur paul vi merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt française
paul on peut dire que cette initiative
américaine marque la fin définitive de
l'accord sur le nucléaire alors c'est
pas sûr très clairement je l'avais déjà
dit sur votre antenne est vraiment
l'intention des etats-unis s'est
tellement clair il espère c'est en
rétablissant rétablissant des sanctions
de l'onu contre l'iran que l'iran
réagissent et les rangs sang de la
couvrait pas les utiliser ta vie c'est
de sortir de l'accord mais d'un recruter
on voit bien tous les autres membres
s'il était d'accord et que eux sont
restés dans l'accord sans contrôle
initiatives des états unis donc je pense
que on rentre dans une période de
tension mais je pense pas que l'accord
soit définitivement thierry coville est
ce que vous êtes toujours avec nous en
toile alors est-ce que ça a coupé sa
coupe et soudainement mis les deux
venant faire face tant mieux si vous
l'êtes
effectivement vous le disiez ça promet
voilà quelques bises vie puisque les
européens sont contre le rétablissement
des sanctions demandées par washington
ils ont affirmé officiellement par un
communiqué ce soir mais pas que la
russie la chine
ça promet une âpre bataille avec les
états unis
je pense que il ya une contradiction
totale dans la position américaine
d'un côté ils disent cantons signataires
de l'accord ils ont le droit de demander
le rétablissement de ces sanctions de
l'onu
d'un autre côté c'est d'accord ils ont
quitté fracas en mai 2018 et ils ont
rappelez vous ils ont même imposer des
sanctions unilatérales à extra
territoriale ou d'android européenne
notamment donc je pense que là il ya une
position des états unis qui est
complètement jusqu'au boutistes qui ne
respecte pas ça c'est pas nouveau le
droit international et ils sont en
complète qu'en dira opposition à tous
les autres signataires de l'accord est
même on va dire à l'esprit des nations
unies dans plage france qui il continue
à mon avis à s'isoler sur le plan
national mais thierry coville
effectivement vous le désir d'en parler
il ya quelques mois avant cette triste
du coronavirus vous avez ici même sur ce
plateau cette bataille elle existait
déjà avec les autres pays est pourtant
aujourd'hui les états unis franche
franchissent une étape supplémentaire ça
veut bien dire qu'ils y
jusqu'au bout malgré tout oui mais il ya
quand même c'est ça aussi qui laisse un
peu d'espoir c'est d'un côté c'est pas
les états unis jusqu aux dernières
nouvelles c'est décide de l'état des
relations internationales et
heureusement et du droit international
et en plus l'esprit et le texte de
l'accord bon alors dans le texte les
jurys sont derrière donald femmes
commencent à dire oui en continu état de
l'accord bâle iii de droit de rétablir
franchement si on garde l'esprit de
l'accord 1 et je vous rappelle que
donald trump le disait que à l'iran de
respecter pas de l'esprit de l'accord
sorti en mai 2010 à l'esprit de l'accord
les etats-unis sont sortis de fracas en
mai 2008 après tout le monde aurait
demandé de rester vacants et là ils ont
quand même le culot de dire on est sûrs
signataires donc je pense qu'il ya eu
l'esprit de l'accord ils ont tous les
membres du conseil de sécurité des
nations-unies
je dirais entre parenthèses ils ont
presque tous les membres associés de
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
contre moi parce que rappelez vous ils
n'ont même pas réussi à ce que leur
résolution pour empêcher la levée de
l'embargo sur les armes
il ya quelques jours atteignent même le
conseil des nations unies ils ont quand
même tout l'ensemble de l'establishment
des nations unies contre eux donc je
pense qu'on va très bien leur intention
était de finir l'accord que le corps
soit mans est justement dans le document
électoral faut espérer quand même que ce
qu'ils défendent le droit international
et je pense que c'est le cas et
notamment le cas les européens et je
suis très content de cette position on
fait en sorte que ces initiatives propos
des tensions mais n'aboutissent pas à la
fin de cet accord qui va même très
important a pris sur la situation à
venir est ce que tu oublies de retard ne
sais que dire en sorte de l'accord et
les cités 500 sans abri venus cuir en
sortir a raconté aux convois sur ces
images vient d'accuser à l'instant les
européens de s'aligner sur les
ayatollahs qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
cette réaction du secrétaire d'état
américain
oui alors qu'il voulait il faut rester
enfin faut rester dans le dans l'analyse
avec le gouvernement américain parce que
quand on regarde comment ils ont fait
moins mal traité le droit international
si les européens sont restés dans
l'accord c'est parce que ils ont
conscience de l'intérêt de cet accord
pour la paix au moyen orient et pour la
lutte contre la prolifération nucléaire
donc on pourrais je pense
les européens ont largement de quoi
multiplier cet argument de des
responsabilités et d'agressivité
vis-à-vis des etats-unis qui en sortant
de cet accord on a créer de
l'instabilité de la région que je
voudrais simplement un exemple en
sortant de cet accord les états unis
auraient habitent leurs sanctions contre
les entreprises européennes et contre
gerrans et les rangs réactions à
commencer à sortir de cet accord
donc je dirais que la situation est
beaucoup plus instable aujourd'hui des
rangs a recommencé enrichir l'uranium à
un niveau supérieur à celui prévu par
l'accord qui rend continue à intervenir
dans la région l'iran développe son
programme balistique
l'iran a plutôt montre les muscles
qu'ils ont peur d'une attaque américaine
donc je vois pas du tout où la politique
américaine et à la stabilité dans la
région donc bon c'est l'accusation de
demain et au belize européen j'espère
une réponse trop vraiment on va dire
traduction à une vie qui perturbe le la
stabilité dans la région
en ce côté orpea pas trop fort mais
c'est plutôt il est élu merci beaucoup
thierry coville d'avoir été avec nous le
rappelle nous est chercheur associé à
l'iris spécialiste de l'iran merci à
vous